il y a toute une analyse du Conseil
d'État qui rappelle que tant sur le plan
euh national que que supranational
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme jurisprudence de la
Cour européenne jurisprudence de la Cour
de justice la loi veille n'est pas
constitutionnellement protégée voilà
cette analyse encore une fois elle n'est
pas mienne elle n'est pas partisane
elle est le fruit d'une réflexion euh
portée par le Conseil d'État et exprimé
mais en des termes qui sont des
termes je les ai qualifiés comme tels et
je le refais en des termes
lumineux alors euh euh le Conseil
d'État nous rappelle qu'en revanche le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité de
la personne humaine a été
consacré comme principe à valeur
constitutionnelle par une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel de
1994 et qu'il en va de même du principe
de liberté de conscience des médecins
consacré comme principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la République
par une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel de
2001 dignité de la personne consacrée au
plus haut niveau liberté de conscience
consacré au plus haut niveau et
liberté garantie à la femme
d'avorter ne serait pas protégé de la
même façon comprenez bien que dans le
trip
il nous manque un élément et cet élément
c'est la protection constitutionnelle
que je souhaiterit que
nous puissions tous ensemble de façon
transpartisan mettre en œuvre et mettre
en place et pour dire les choses
clairement la sauvegarde de la dignité
humaine la liberté de conscience des
médecins ont déjà valeurs
constitutionnelle et la liberté d'avoir
recours à l'IVG
non
bon cette seule question
est est la réponse à cette seule
question devrait me semble-t-il nous
inciter à adopter le texte